thank you for the introduction for
organizing and for letting me speak this
is joint work with my adviser Jacob Fox
and his former student you Fay Joe so
I'll talk about the regularity lemma and
algorithmically
and then the usual regularity lemma then
freeze cannon regularity lemma and an
algorithmic version and then I'll give
sketches of what we have the things that
we approved so seven eighties regularity
lemma I'll go I'll quickly go over this
sorry if this is review but so roughly
speaking it says that in any graph you
can partition the vertices into a
bounded number of parts such that
between almost all pairs of parts the
graph between them is random like so
here for example we have the partition
and then between these two parts we have
some maybe small density between these
two we have some larger density and this
is a very important tool in graph theory
with lots of applications and it gives a
nice rough structural result that holds
for all graphs so to be more precise let
x and y be two sets of vertices in a
graph G and then denote by e XY the
number of pairs of vertices in X cross Y
that have an edge between them and D XY
is normalized so that's the density
between them and then the definition of
an epsilon regular pair is that we have
two sets of vertices x and y
and their epsilon regular if any two
subsets x-prime y-prime
that contain it at least an epsilon
fraction of the vertices the density
between X prime and y prime is off from
the total density between x and y by at
most Epsilon so roughly if x and y are
epsilon regular for a small epsilon then
the graph between them is random like
pseudo random now so to say similarities
regularity lemma so first for a
partition we'll say that it's equitable
if the sizes are roughly equal as equals
they can be and and then given an
equitable partition we will say that
this partition is epsilon regular if
alba an epsilon fraction of the pair's
or epsilon regular and then cemeteries
regularity lemma says that for any
epsilon there is an M of epsilon such
that for any graph G there's an
equitable epsilon regular partition into
at most M of epsilon parts so let me
sketch the proof quickly because and
then we'll see where it is and isn't
algorithmic so so the central notion is
the mean square density of a partition
so given a partition the mean square
density is the weighted average based on
the sizes of the partitions of the
square density between pairs of parts
and this value this is a value between 0
& 1 and the nice thing is that if we
refine a partition this cannot decrease
you can prove this by let's say a Koshi
inequality and then and furthermore what
what happens is if we so if we have a
partition into K parts with a graph say
here
so then if it's not epsilon regular then
we can refine it so for VI VJ let's say
this pair is not epsilon regular then we
take the pair of bad sets and we refine
VI by this bad set and VJ by this bad
set and then maybe VI is also not
epsilon regular with some other VK so
then we take this pair of bad sets and
refine it further so in this way we've
divided each part of the original
partition if it had K parts into at most
two to the k plus 1 parts and you can
show using a Cosi defect inequality that
in this way the mean square density will
increase by epsilon to the fifth so then
the way the proof goes is you take a
partition may be trivial partitioner or
small partition you check if it's
epsilon regular if it is you're done if
it's not then we refine it and then
slightly refine it further to make it
equitable and then we keep iterating
this and this can only happen one over
epsilon to the five times after that
many steps you must end up with an
epsilon regular partition and so what
does this give 4m of Epsilon so you get
an exponential in the number of parts in
each steps so it gives a tower function
so if we let T of n be 2 to the 2 to the
2 and x then this gives M of epsilon is
at most tower epsilon to the minus 5 and
Gower's and later subsequent work well
Gareth showed and subsequent work
improved that upon the fact that you
actually need a tower a tower function
here as a lower bound on F of Epsilon
okay so how can we make this regular
well the main challenge is if we have
two sets x and y how do we check if it's
regular or how do we find a pair that's
not regular because you can't just check
all subsets well if you can that's the
basic problem to solve because then you
can do the same proof by taking the bad
sets and refining so I'll own Duke left
and riddle and yester showed that if a
pair XY is not epsilon regular then they
can find a pair of subsets that show
that they're not epsilon to the four
regular they do this by basically
observing that so a pair is epsilon
regular a pair being epsilon regular is
up to changing epsilon by something
equivalent to the C four count between
the two sets being what not being close
to what you would expect in a regular in
a random graph and the C four count then
you can I mean the C four count between
x and y is kind of the trace of a a
transpose a transpose and so this gives
an algorithm which runs in time o
epsilon n to the omega plus little o one
where Omega is the matrix multiplication
constant which is known to be less than
two point three seven three so freeze
can and freezing cannon also gave an
algorithmic proof through a spectral
approach looking at the singular values
now this was improved by kochava rudl
and Toma who gave uh N squared
algorithmic lemma by basically showing
that you can find a good expander graph
and test along edges just in that
expander the KO degree condition which
is another equivalent condition to the
c-4 count
and another result in this area is
although in an hour
I have an algorithm on Oh mealtime
algorithm which can approximate the cut
norm I'll say that is later up to a
constant factor and they use this to get
a polynomial time algorithm with T o of
epsilon to the minus seven parts so here
even though so so the regularity lemma
of course we know that a tower is
necessary if you want it for all graphs
but many graphs actually have a much
smaller regularity partition most graphs
even by some sense and the previous
algorithms there's no guarantee that
even if the graph has a small one they
would find it so in so to look at this
problem
Fisher mutts Leah and Shapira give a
randomized algorithm which runs in
constant time for a fixed epsilon and K
and the if the algorithm has the
property that if the graph has an
epsilon regular partition with K parts
it finds a to epsilon regular partition
into at most K parts this
yeah so so this constant time means if
it's if you're okay with it being
implicitly defined then it runs in
constant time otherwise you multiply it
by N and then the partition and late to
this is a full kind of folklore that's
written down in a blog post of Terry tau
which is a randomized algorithm for the
regularity lemma that runs in constant
time and gives an epsilon regular
partition basically its samples a random
set of points from the graph and then
your partition is basically how the
points are connected to this fixed
random set so that's why it's implicitly
defined by just this set of random
points
so our result for this is N squared time
deterministic algorithm so these are
randomized algorithms our results is a
deterministic algorithm which given
which also basically does the same thing
so if there's an epsilon regular
partition on K Vord with K parts then we
find a slightly worse partition into K
parts for it for any fixed out that we
can do it in n squared time and an
intermediate result towards this is a
result to test the regularity for a
single pair of parts so we give a
deterministic algorithm which given
epsilon and alpha and a graph G between
x and y outputs either that this pair is
epsilon regular or it gives a pair of
subsets that show that they're not
slightly worse at 1 minus alpha times
epsilon regular oh yeah sorry there yes
sorry sorry so that case should be there
and not there
okay so because of the large number of
parts in the regularity lemma it's there
other versions have been developed so
there's the freeze cannon regularity
lemma also called the week regularity
lemma so given a partition of the set of
vertices we say that it's free scan and
epsilon regular if for any pair of sets
s and T the number of edges between s
and T is close to the number of edges
you would expect between s and T kind of
if all you knew about s and T is their
sizes and their sizes inside each of the
parts of the partition right because
then you would expect between SI for
each I and J you would expect this many
edges between these two sets so if this
count is off by at most epsilon times by
at most epsilon times V squared then we
say that the partition is free scan and
epsilon regular and then the free scan
and regularity lemma says that for any
epsilon greater than zero every graph
has a free scan and epsilon regular
partition into at most an exponential in
epsilon poly Epsilon
number of parts and here I'm not
concentrating on this we can also
require this to be equitable and the
proof of this is similar except now
instead of refining for each pair by the
worst case you refined by a single pair
of sets globally so we have globally an
s and T so if you have a partition
that's not free scan irregular you
globally have a pair of sets whose
densities are off and you refine by that
pair and you can show that the mean
square density increases by epsilon
squared and you get a factor of four in
the number of parts so here basically
this partition so this property of the
partition is weaker but in exchange we
get a much smaller weekly regular
partition
so the a common application cutting it's
common in applications of the regularity
lemma to combine it with the counting
lemma so to state the version that we
use its easiest to state if we first
define this notion of cut distance so if
we have two graphs g1 and g2 on the same
vertex set we define their cut distance
as the maximum over pairs of sets of the
difference between the number of edges
between them normalized to be between 0
and 1 and in this language a partition P
is free scan and epsilon regular its if
and only if the cut distance of G from
this other graph GP where GP is defined
as so let's say we have a partition of
the vertex set and then between so let's
say Parts VI and VJ we have weighted
edges of weight the density between VI
and VJ and you do this for all pairs of
parts including within parts so the
partition is free scan an epsilon
regular if and only if the cut distance
between these two graphs is small and
then this language we the counting lemma
says that for any graph on K vertices if
you don't know what the homomorphism
count is you could basically think of it
as a number of copies of H ng up to a
lower des term so the difference between
the the number of copies of H and one
and the other is bounded by the number
of edges in H times they're cut distance
times n to the K
so now how can this be made algorithmic
there are two results due to della
Monica kalyana Sundaram Martin brutal
and Shapira in this direction so first
they give a deterministic algorithm
which finds a free scan and epsilon
regular partition in time polynomial in
epsilon times n to the Omega and in a
later work double exponential and
epsilon and square no an N squared so so
you reduce Omega to N squared here at
the cost of worse dependence on epsilon
and the main tool for the I mean the
main meat of the problem is finding the
back pair so for example for the first
result the what they do is they show
that there's an end to the Omega plus a
little one time algorithm which given an
epsilon in an N vertex graph and a
partition of the vertices that either
correctly states that this partition is
free scan an epsilon regular or it finds
a pair of sets which show that it's not
epsilon cubed regular and in this result
there's an analogous statement for N
squared and so what this means is that
we can say a bit more we we can say that
there's a polynomial and epsilon n to
the Omega type algorithm which given an
epsilon and n vertex graph outputs a T
the polynomial and pairs of sets SI TI
with CI such that we have this such that
our graph is in cut distance very close
to being this other weighted graph which
has this short description where it's
you start with the every edge having
weight the average weight in G and then
you add the CI may be negative but you
we add just these KS ITI between them so
you add these bipartite graphs between
Si and TI and we can also here decrease
Omega 2 to the cost of a wheres
dependence on epsilon you can say that
they're not disjoint and then this KS
iti you have to define properly you can
also just multiply it by 3 I think or
and then make them disjoint
okay so so what we apply this to is this
problem of counting is a problem of
counting sub-graphs
so the basic algorithmic problem is
we're given a large graph G and a small
graph H and can we count the number of
copies of H in G now doing this exactly
is np-hard
in fact just checking whether there's
single copy is np-hard
in fact so that in fact so in this
direction Zukerman showed that it's
np-hard to even to approximate let's say
H is a cleek even if you want to just
approximate the size of the largest
clique with an effective n to the 1
minus epsilon this is np-hard this is
show building on an earlier result of HA
stud so what we look at is okay so how
fast can we approximate this if we allow
an additive error of epsilon times n to
the vh so we so if H is on K vertices G
is on n vertices then we want to count
the number of copies of H in the graph
with an area of that most epsilon times
n to the K so a simple so if you allow
randomized algorithms there's a pretty
simple algorithm here which is just you
sample okay sets of vertices and you
keep repeating that ten over epsilon
squared times this is a binomial
distribution and so it's highly
concentrated if you take large enough so
with high probability it'll be within
epsilon the fraction of times you see H
in a random K sample will be with an
epsilon of the total fraction of H so
what about deterministic algorithms so
you can use algorithmic regularity lemma
and so if you use the usual regularity
lemma you could get a regular partition
and and then you can use the densities
in that regularity partition to count
the copies of age
so Duke left men and brutal developed a
different version of weak regularity
lemma and use this to show that it can
be done in time and to the Omega times
exponential in K over epsilon and what
we show is that this can be done in time
for a fixed stage polynomial in epsilon
and n so for example what this means is
we can count the number of copies of K
1000 with the small with an additive
error and to the 1000 minus 1 over 1
million in time Big O and to the 2.4 ok
let me now in the time remaining sketch
our proofs so let's look at the counting
sub graphs first so we apply algorithmic
free scannin here and that's where the
that so for that term we the algorithm
takes that long and we get this graph G
prime which has this nice structure and
the cut distance of G from G prime is at
most epsilon divided by the number of
edges of H and so by the algorithmic
free scan we can guarantee that T is at
most a polynomial in epsilon and what
this means is that the count of H in G
and in G prime is off by at most epsilon
times n to the K so we can just count
the number of copies of H in G prime and
to do that because we have this nice
form we can do we basically do the graph
version of the distributive property so
we compute this home H G prime by
computing a sum of T plus 1 to the eh
terms where each term corresponds to
assigning each edge of H to one of these
terms and it's a kind of way to like
multi-coloured edged homomorphism
density
so I don't want to go into details but I
hope the main idea here is clear so now
let me sketch the proof of the other
result so first this testing regularity
between a pair of sets x and y with a
small interval of error so again we
apply the algorithmic freeze cannon
regularity lemma with distance alpha
times epsilon cubed over 4 so we obtain
a graph G Prime at that distance and
what this basically what again what
because of how we've chosen this
distance the bound on the cut distance
we can work with G Prime in the sense
that they're kind of how regular they
are is off by at most alpha epsilon over
4 so we slightly decrease this interval
instead of epsilon and 1 minus alpha
times Epsilon it's at 1 minus alpha over
4 times Epsilon and 1 minus 3/4 itself
times Epsilon and then we work with G
Prime
and now for G prime so how do we test
this for G Prime
so we have big sets X&Y so now suppose
we have you subset X and W subset Y so
in order to determine the density but
between U and W in G prime we only need
to know the size of U the size of W this
and the size of each intersect each you
intersect Si and the size of each W
intersect Ti because then if we have the
all of these values we can plug it into
this formula and check the density so
now we can't well we can't check it for
every single intersection size but we
can take a net of possible intersection
sizes a bounded net and check for all
those and so for each point in this kind
of net we have to check two things first
we have to check whether it's feasible
so whether there actually exists a U and
W with those sizes and intersection
sizes and second whether the density is
off so there are some details I'm
skipping over here but this is a basic
idea
and then to apply this to gay to get a
small regularity partition oh sorry so
so as a corollary of this result we can
also for a fixed K we can check
regularity of the partition of size k
with again a small interval of error so
between epsilon and 1 plus alpha times
epsilon so now to finish the proof of
the of checking finding a regular
partition without most K parts so again
we apply the algorithmic free scannin
regularity lemma and here again we
choose the distance so that we can work
with regular partitions of G Prime
instead of G and so again this will if
we switch from G to G Prime the way
we've chosen the distance the how
regular the partition the possible K
part partitions are can change by at
most alpha epsilon over 4 and and then
in G prime the only thing that matters
for a k part partition that's a
candidate to be regular is how it
divides up each part of the free scannin
partition so 4 so again we take a net of
possible size of partitions K partitions
and for each point in this net we apply
the previous algorithm to check whether
its regularity to check its regularity
between 1 plus alpha over 2 epsilon and
1 plus 3 PI over 4 epsilon and at some
point we must get that it's regular and
then that means it must be slightly
worsley regular for G so again I'm
skipping over details here but this is
the basic idea of the proof
so to summarize we use this so there's
this algorithmic free scan of regularity
lemma okay to two versions due to della
Monica kalyanasundaram Martin riddle and
Shapira and we use this finite sum
structure this is true just in general
for the week regularity lemma that gives
this finite sum structure in addition to
just the partition and we can use this
to count the number of copies of a small
graph H integrety
efficiently and we can also use this to
more efficiently find and tests the
regularity of sets and of partitions so
some open questions here this was posed
yesterday as well in the open problem
session can we get a faster free skin
and regularity lemma and another open
question is if we're counting the number
of copies of H in a graph G so we did it
with epsilon into the K error can you do
it with the small area like small area
like n to the K half where can you prove
that you can't have a smaller error and
I'll finish here thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
well so if you have constant time then
you can't explore can only explore a
constant yeah I think there should
always be a small probability that it's
you got a very unlucky sample like
copies of each and then that has like
ennovation a pervert is either you can
think that's some sampling process and
if you there's only so many crafts you
can just probe not a kanessa said a
constant number but a polynomial number
and then we give you an additive error
which is where the exponent out of air
is doesn't isn't so bad as it results in
India where palm you
maybe
[Applause]